hello this is Matthew with simply lying
and today we're gonna go through a real
tough battle we're gonna decide which is
better for your operations environment
is it chef puppet ansible or saltstack
all four are gonna go head-to-head so
let's go through the scenario or why
you'd want to use these tools so let's
meet Tim he's our system administrator
and Tim is a happy camper pretty and
working on all of the systems in his
network well what happens if their
system fails if there's a fire a server
goes down well Tim knows exactly what to
do he can fix that fire really easily
the problems become really difficult for
Tim however if multiple servers start
failing particularly when you have large
and expanding networks so this is why
Tim really needs to have a configuration
management tool and we need to now
decide what would be the best tool for
him because configuration management
tools can help make Tim look like a
superstar all he has to do is configure
the right codes that allows him to push
out the instructions on how to set up
each of the servers quickly effectively
and at scale all right let's go through
the tools and see which ones we can use
the tools that we're going to go through
our chef puppet and support and salts
tags and we have videos on most of these
software services that you can go and
view to get an overview or a deep dive
in how those products work so let's go
and get to know our contestants so our
first contestant is chef and chef is a
tool that allows you to configure very
large environments it allows you to
scale very effectively across the entire
ecosystem and infrastructure chef is by
default an open source code and one of
the things that you find is a consistent
metaphor for the tools that we recommend
on simply learned is to use open source
code the code itself is actually written
in language of Ruby and Erlang and it's
really designed for heterogeneous
infrastructures that are looking for a
mature solution
the way that chef works is that you
write recipes that are compiled into
cookbooks and those cookbooks are the
definition of how you would set up a
node and a node is a selection of
servers that you have configured in a
specific way so for instance you may
have Apache Linux servers running or you
may have a my sequel server running you
may have a Python server running and
chef is able to communicate back and
forth between the nodes to understand
what nodes are being impacted and need
to have instructions sent out to them to
correct that impact you can also send
instructions from the server to the
nodes to make a significant update or a
minor update so there's great
communication going back and forth if we
look at the pros and cons but the pros
for chef is that there is a significant
following for chef and that has resulted
in a very large collection of recipes
that allow you to be able to quickly
stand up in Bryans there's no need for
you to have to learn complex recipes the
first thing you should do is go out and
find the recipes that are available
it integrates with get really well and
fries for really good strong version
control some of the konso are really
around the learning speed it takes to go
from beginner user with chef to being an
expert there is a considerable amount of
learning that has to take place and it's
compounded by having to learn Ruby as
the programming language and the main
server itself doesn't really have a
whole lot of control it's really
dependent on the communication
throughout the whole network alright
let's look at our second contender
puppet and puppet is actually in many
ways very similar to chef there are some
differences but again puppet is designed
to be able to support very large
heterogeneous organization it is also
built with Ruby and uses DSL for writing
manifests so there are some strong
similarities here to chef as with a chef
there is a master/slave infrastructure
with puppet and you have a master server
that has the manifests that you put
together in a single catalogue and those
catalogs are then pushed out to the
clients over an ssl can
action some of the pros with puppet is
that as with chef there is a really
strong community around puppies and
there's just a great amount of
information and support that you can get
right out of the gate it is a very
well-developed reporting mechanism that
makes it easier for you as an
administrator to be able to understand
your infrastructure one of the cons is
that you have to really be good at
learning Ruby again as with Chef you
know the more advanced tasks really need
to have those Ruby skills and as with
Chef the server also doesn't have much
control so let's look at our third
contender here ansible and so ansible is
slightly different it is the way the
animal works is that it actually just
pushes out the instructions to the
server environment there isn't a client
server or master slave environment where
as well would be communicating backwards
and forwards with its infrastructure it
is merely gonna push that instructions
out the good news is that the
instructions are written in yeah Mel and
Yael stands for Gamal ain't markup
language Gamal is actually pretty easy
to learn if you know XML and XML is
pretty easy if you know XML you're gonna
get yeah Moe really well as well it does
work very well on environments where the
focuses of getting servers up and
running really fast it's very very
responsive and can allow you to move
quickly to get your infrastructure up
quick very fast and we're talking
seconds and minutes here really really
quick so again the way that ansible
works is that you put together a
playbook and an inventory or you have a
playbook so the way that ansible works
is that you have a playbook and the
playbook if then goes against the
inventory of servers and will push out
the instructions for that playbook to
those servers so some of the pros that
we have for ansible we don't need to
have an agent install on the remote
nodes and servers it makes it easier for
the configuration yamo is really easy to
learn you can get up to speed and get
very proficient with llamó quickly the
actual performance once you actually
have your infrastructure up and running
is less than other tools that we have in
our list now I do have to add
this is a relative less it's still very
fast it's gonna be a lot faster than
individuals and manually standing up
servers but it's just not as fast as
some of the other tools that we have on
this list and gamma itself as a language
while it's easy to learn it's not as
powerful as Ruby Ruby will allow you to
do things that at an advanced level that
you can't do easily with the mo so let's
look at our final contender here
saltstack so saltstack
is a CLI based tool it means that you
will have to get your command-line tools
out or your terminal window out so you
can actually manage the entire
environment via saltstack the
instructions themselves are based on
Python but you can actually write them
in llamo or DSL which is really
convenient and as a product it's really
designed for environments that want to
scale quickly and be very resilient the
way that salt Snap works is that you
have a master environment that pushes
out the instructions to pickled grains
which is your network and so let's step
through some of the pros and cons that
we have here with salts tag so so suck
is very easy to use once it's up and
running it has a really good reporting
mechanism that makes it your job as an
operator in your DevOps environment much
much easier the actual setup though is a
little bit tougher than some of the
other tools and and it's getting easier
with the newer releases but it's just a
little bit tougher and related to that
is that salt stank is fairly late in the
game when it comes to actually having a
graphical user interface for being able
to create and manage your environment
other tools such as ansible have
actually had a UI environment for quite
some time alright so we've gone through
all four tools let's see how they all
stack up next to each other so let the
race begin let's start with the first
stage architecture so the architecture
for most of our environments is a server
client environment so for chef puppet
and salt snack so very similar
architecture there the one exception is
ansible which is a client only solution
so you're pushing out the
instructions from a server and pushing
them out into your network and there
isn't a client environments that there
isn't a two-way communication back to
that main client for what's actually
happening in your network so let's talk
about the next stage ease of setup so we
look at the four tools there is one tool
that really stands out for ease of setup
and that is ansible it is gonna be the
easiest tool for you to set up and if
you're new to having these types of
tools in your environment you may want
to start with ansible just to try out
and see how easy is to create automated
configuration before looking at other
tools now and so with that said chef
puppet and sauce sack aren't that hard
to set up either and you'll find there's
actually some great instructions on how
to do that setup in the online community
let's talk about the languages that you
can use in your configuration so we have
two different types of language with
both chef and ansible being procedural
and that they actually specify at how
you're actually supposed to do the tasks
in your instructions with puppet and
saltstack
it's decorative where you specify only
what to do in the instructions let's
talk about scalability which tools scale
the most effectively and as you can
imagine all of these tools are designed
for scalability that is the driver for
these kind of tools you want them to be
able to scale to massive organizations
what did the management tools look like
for our four contenders so again we have
a two-way split with an spawn saltstack
that management tools are really easy to
use you don't love using them they're
just fantastic to use with puppet and
chef the management tools are much
harder to learn and they do require that
you learn some either the puppet DSL or
the Ruby DSL to be able to be a true
master in that environment but what does
interoperability look like again as
you'd imagine with the similar to
scalability interoperability with these
products is very high in all four cases
now let's talk about cloud availability
this is increasingly becoming more
important for
organizations as they move rapidly on to
cloud services well both ansible and
suits tank have a big fail here neither
of them are available in the most
popular cloud environments and Puppet
and chef are actually available in both
Amazon and Asia we've actually just
haven't had a chance to update our chef
link here but chef is now available on
Asia as well as Amazon so what does
communication look like with all of our
four tools so the communication is
slightly different with them chef has
its own knife tool and whereas puppet
uses SSL Secure Sockets Layer and
ansible and sort sec use secure socket
hashing and SSH as their communication
tool bottom line all four tools are very
secure in their communication so who
wins well here's the reality all four
tools are very good and its really
dependent on your capabilities and the
type of environment that you're looking
to manage that will determine which of
these four tools you should use the
tools themselves are open sourced so go
out and experiment with them there's a
lot of videos our team has done a ton of
videos on these tools and so feel free
to find out other tools that we have
then covered so you can learn very
quickly how to use them but consider the
requirements that you have and consider
the capabilities of your team if you
have Ruby developers or you have someone
on your team that knows Ruby your
ability to choose a broader set of tools
becomes much more interesting if however
you're new to coding then you may want
to consider
yamo based tools again the final answer
is going to be up to you and we'll be
really interested on what your decision
is please post in the comments below
which tool you have decided to go with
and what are the challenges that you're
I'm coming up with because we'll help
answer those challenges for you and if
you find that you liked this video you
may want to check out some of the other
videos that we have that are based on
the four products that we've covered
here and we have a lot of videos that do
overview Andy
dives on each of these products
including demonstrations on how to
actually implement and start the
fundamentals of working with these
products and if you liked this video hit
the subscribe button followed by the
bell so you get notified of any new
videos that we have coming out we have
two to three new videos coming out every
single week
this is Matthew from simply learn I hope
you've really enjoyed the next stage in
your dev ops journey hi there if you
liked this video subscribe to the simple
learn youtube channel and click here to
watch similar videos de nerd up and get
certified click here